[Musique]
avec nous frank pons doyen de la faculté
des sciences de l'administration à
l'université laval et directeur de
l'observatoire international en
management du sport bonjour monsieur
pons
bonsoir bonsoir je les ai professeur la
victoire du canadien ne fait pas
seulement plaisir aux femmes
il ya toute une industrie qui en profite
excusez moi j'ai pas compris la question
je vous je vous posais la question je
voudrais que hier soir ce qu'on a bien
compris ce n'est pas seulement les fans
qui sont heureux de cette victoire
il ya toute une industrie qui profite
aussi de ce retournement tout à fait
tout à fait c'est évident quelque chose
qui est très documenté que les passages
en syrie et les longues séries pour une
équipe qui sera jusqu'à la finale que ce
soit une bille et que ce soit chez
apporte énormément de revenus
additionnels est également une notoriété
est très importante pour la malle docsis
est très bénéfique
c'est bénéfique à de nombreux points de
vue mais il faut pas mettre tout sur le
sport et c'est souvent ce qu'on voit ses
clés mais les stratèges en marketing du
sport dans les équipes mais développe
une marque faure et espère que la
victoire sportive ou l'avancé le plus
longtemps dans la saison mais ce sera un
bonus et c'est ce qu'on voit
actuellement avec le canadien un bon
bonus pour l'équipe qu'elle a besoin
pour la ligue aussi bah oui parce qu'une
équipe qui performent une équipe qui
gagne une équipe qui surpassent les
attentes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vous diriez
au niveau du marketing au niveau des
retombées économiques
elles sont très variées comme nous le
dit d'abord des aspects très simple
qu'on peut pas vivre actuellement
si au niveau de la billetterie à
montréal ont le plus difficilement avec
les suites de la pandémie en tout cas on
a plus de spectateurs bien en deçà des
sommets donc se rapporter au centre bell
par contre tous les produits dérivés
on voit une augmentation très marquante
la plupart des études qui ont été faites
pour montréal
les études datent depuis longtemps parce
qu'on n'est pas allé aussi loin depuis
93 mais ce qu'on voit on avait avec les
raptors en avait que les blues de st
louis à on voit d augmentation marquée
des dépenses notamment en produits
dérivés comme vous l'avez dit parce que
en fait au delà des fans ainsi que je
dirais que l'équipe s'impliquent et qui
restent fidèles à leur image beaucoup
plus l'âge des gens qui sont à la
périphérie et qui avec cet engouement
des
beaucoup plus sur ces produits dérivés
l'aï donc ça c'est la partie la plus
importante on parle d'augmentation entre
30 et 70 % dépendamment des jours de
match est donc cet aspect là et que les
commanditaires avons également rentrer
un jeu vous allez voir dans les années
qui viennent on va se rapprocher parce
que l'équipe bonne bénéficie en fait de
cette visibilité additionnel et surtout
de la commande publique
à une époque on a bien besoin et les
sponsors seront également professeur
pense qu'est ce que ça veut dire en
termes de retombées
si on élargit un peu aux retombées que
ça représente pour montréal et pour le
québec en général pour les villes que je
dis les gars nos études convoi elles
sont très variables
on voit on a parlé pour les blues de
saint louis par exemple une augmentation
de 50 millions de revenus additionnels
on se méfie un petit peu parce que
effectivement il ya certains industrie
on parle des bars actuellement des
restaurants qui bénéficie grandement les
gens sortent beaucoup plus vous passez
aussi aux gens qui regardent le match en
groupe leur mini super bowl c'est notre
mini super bowl
à l'heure actuelle et pensent beaucoup
dans des idées aussi grosse quantité
par contre les revenus additionnels
qu'on voit d'habitude notamment au
niveau des hôtels avec beaucoup de
déplacements et attire des foules besson
on le voit moins un poste de la pandémie
mais c'est des sommes très importantes
deere a servi on parlait de 50 millions
pour la grande périphérie en plus on
parle on a parlé des chiffres
astronomiques d'un milliard par exemple
pour toronto avec avec les raptors sur
une période de dix ans parce qu'il faut
comprendre que l'impact le cas cette
présence est avancé et les retombées
pour la ville
elles ne s'arrêteront pas de demain vous
allez avoir des touristes qui ont
entendu parler du des canadiens de
montréal est normal de des compatriotes
à moi français qui m'écrivent justement
on parlait du canadien et qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire en arrivant à montréal
l'année prochaine dans deux ans ils vont
acheter des produits va vouloir aller
voir le centre bell il va avoir des
dépenses additionnelles et donc ses
revenus à vont s'étaler dans le temps et
c'est ça qui est important c'est revenu
rémanents qui ne sont pas habituelles
quand on n'a pas un parcours très très
sportif on se base plutôt sur notre
équité de marque sur notre capital de
marque le bonus c'est la victoire
sportive c'est l'avancé le plus loin
possible on espère pour les canadiens
c'est la coupe stanley qui est elle
rapportait encore beaucoup plus enviable
d'image loto la barre a justement
professeur l'on parle des prochains
matchs
dit que ça devrait être un moral et 2,5
et possiblement 9 juillet au plus tard
on dit que ça se terminerait le 11
juillet place inhabituelle que ce soit
si tard dans l'année qu'est ce que ça
change vous diriez la dynamique pour les
gens sur le terrain
ben vous le voyez dans les rues beaucoup
de monde dans les rues qui peuvent
partager beaucoup de fêtes aussi chez
des gens dans la dalle et les cours
arrière déjà très catchy et regarde le
match
la période estivale elle est déjà
propice à se retrouver à partager à
dépenser elle est encore plus propice
cette année parce qu'on sort d'une
pandémie qui a duré 18 mois où les gens
veulent se retrouver
ajoutez à ça au mix le canadien de
montréal fait battre les coeurs de tout
le monde et encore une fois je parle pas
des fans de sport là on est beaucoup
plus loin que le sport dans la com la la
tempête parfaite au bon moment c'est une
tempête plutôt un soleil parfait on
espère que l'été va être beau jusqu'au
mois de juillet jusqu'à mi juillet au
moins pour que les gens puissent vivre
le canadien dans la rue partagée sortir
dépensés pour relancer notre économie
quelque part également aussi rejouer
dans la question rapidement le lien qui
se bâtit entre l'équipe et ses fins dans
les gens ont maintenant sont fiers de sa
fiche est de prendre pour les canadiens
de montréal
quelle est l'importance du guerrier mars
qu'il vient de se passer la création ce
sentiment d'appartenance qui doit avoir
aussi ou permettre certaines retombées
le lien est parti c'était intéressant
parce que vous avez une excellente
question si vous remontez pas très
longtemps dans la saison 1 la saison
passée les ya deux saisons il ya trois
saisons ainsi que l'image de marque
d'une équipe était passible le lieu
était parfois et là vous voyez ce qu'on
parle de roche
mais non il va y avoir un rôle très
important de l'équipe qu'on gagne ou
qu'on gagne pas la coupe stanley parce
que la halle à l'avancé la pousse et
qu'on a fait est magnifique et elle elle
transmet normal de bonnes valeurs
on va espérer qu'on gagne la coupe
stanley mais falloir que l'équipe en
termes de marketing travaille énormément
sur le renforcement de ce lien là il ne
porte une opportunité immense on a
oublié beaucoup de choses qu'on reproche
aux canadiens il faut qu'à partir de la
saison prochaine à partir de cette
victoire après la coupe stanley on
espère s'il y a là ils sont
continuellement développer renforcée
avec une stratégie marketing qui jouera
oui sur la victoire mais aussi sur une
proximité avec la population et des
valeurs qu'on partage bon le professeur
va profiter du seuil vous êtes là pour
vous demander à ce qu'on laisse le
canadien va affronter tampa bay où nous
y avons passé
il est comme tout le monde on espère
dans l'adversité qu'on réussit le mieux
en fait on devrait dire qu'ils qu'on
affronte c'est pas très important
l'important c'est les chercher la
victoire et on va tous être derrière le
canadien même si j'ai commenté j'ai déjà
dit sur vos ondes
tu as fan des nordiques mais je pense
que pour quelques semaines mais continue
à supporter les canadiens merci frank
pons doyen de la faculté des sciences de
l'administration à l'université laval
merci d'avoir été des nôtres
merci bonne journée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit